A couple of announcements: tomorrow
we will resume testing.
We will have quiz eight based on
the two versions of homework seven,
one of which the second one, the
beta version, I've relabeled
homework eight.
And, it's posted on the Web as such.
So that there's no confusion,
there's a homework seven, second
homework seven: one focused on x-ray
diffraction, and the other one had
x-ray diffraction and defects.
So, that's the subject matter for
tomorrow's ten minute test.
And, I think that's all I have by
way of introduction.
Anybody recognize the music?
Philip Glass, yes. What else would
you play if you are teaching
amorphous solids?
You could play something like Glass
Onion by The Beatles if you can
stand the Beatles.
But, I didn't want to do that.
Oh yeah, there's people my
generation, two categories: those
who think the Beatles are great,
and those who think they are just,
ahem, and I'm in the second category.
They bore me. Anyways,
this is what we were looking at.
So, what we want to do today is
continue the treatment of glasses.
Last day, we saw that amorphous
solids were formed under certain
conditions. And these were the
three that we enunciated.
Glass formation is enhanced.
And here I'm talking about liquid
to solid.
We can also form glasses by vapor to
solid. But, I'm talking about the
dominant form of glass formation.
If we have a highly viscous liquid
that is trying to rearrange itself
to find a rather complex crystal
structure in the solid,
and the cooling rate is very,
very rapid, those three factors
together will make it difficult for
the atoms to find their proper
lattice sites.
And as a result,
some of the disorder of the liquid
will be quenched in.
And the result will be a glass.
And, today I want to study a
particular form of glass which is
the dominant one you know: silicate
glasses. And,
these are based on silica.
And, we are going to study their
structure and their properties today.
And so, the first thing we want to
recognize is that we are talking
about something that's inorganic and
covalent. It's covalent in both
silicon and oxygen.
We form sp3 hybrids.
So, we have the capability of
forming four bonds.
And, obviously,
oxygen forms two,
and then two of its pairs of
electrons are in non-bonding
orbitals. Silicon,
on the other hand, has four
electrons, each of which shares.
And, the difference between what
you're seeing here and what you are
seeing in something like diamond is
that in diamond or in crystalline
silicon, all of the atoms on the
board would be the same.
We'd have either all carbons sp3
hybridized, or all silicons
sp3 hybridized.
Here we've got silicons and oxygens.
So, each silicon has four oxygens
as nearest neighbors.
And, if the atoms align perfectly,
we will end up with something that
is crystalline.
But, Tom, if we could go to the
document camera and like to show
what the basics of glass formation
are. Consider the yellow atoms as
being silicons and the gray
atoms as being oxygen.
So, you see, every silicon has four
oxygen atoms. And,
every oxygen atom lies between two
silicon atoms.
And, these are both sp3 hybridized,
but there's a difference. The
difference is that in the case of
silicon, all four bonds are
specified in space.
But in the case of oxygen,
this bond here, the bond that
bridges the two silicons,
it can maintain the 109í angle,
but rotate because the other two
orbitals are simply containing
nonbonding electrons.
So, because this is free to rotate,
we have the possibility that in the
liquid state, it's twisting and
turning every which way.
And then, as the temperature drops,
and the material is getting the
signal, it's time to form the solid.
These have to twist around. They
have to align themselves perfectly.
If they do so, we'll end up with
something that looks like this.
Now, this, strictly speaking, is
not crystalline quartz.
It's a cousin of it.
It's a vertside structure.
But again, you can see sp3
hybridized yellow atoms with
bridging gray atoms.
And, when everything lines up we
end up with something that's a
three-dimensional crystal.
So, you see something that is net
cubic. You've got two atoms per
lattice point and so on.
There's an 001 plane, 002,
and so on. Everything is making
sense. And the same thing happens
here. If this falls and forms on a
line, then these three will line up
as they do across this 011 face.
But, if the solidification occurs at
a rate too rapid to allow everything
to twist around,
we end up with something that fails
to achieve crystallinity.
So, this is the origin of the
crystal structure that we see here.
So, again, just to recap, the
silicon bonds specified,
they're fully specified.
They are specified in three
directions, whereas the oxygen bonds
are specified only in two dimensions,
and therefore,
there is one degree of freedom.
And, this is where the cooling rate
comes into play because the cooling
rate can quench in the motion before
everything has twisted to rearrange
itself. So, the first thing to note,
second thing is that we observed
that this can continue
without limit.
There's no reason for this to
terminate. So,
we have long chains here.
So, this is, in essence, a polymer.
This is a polymer, and SiO2 is the
mer unit. You might say,
well gee, I see four oxygens bonded
to the silicon.
But each oxygen is shared by two
silicons. So stoichiometrically,
it's SiO2. It all comes out in the
wash.
So, you could think of this as long
spaghetti. That's what we're
looking at: molecules that are very
long. And, to make matters worse,
they entangle in the liquid. So,
they crisscross each other.
And now, they have to disentangle
and line up in such a way as to give
us something that is crystalline.
So, what about evidence of disorder?
Tom, may we go to the computer
graphic please?
So, if we want to look for evidence
of disorder, let's use some
x-ray diffraction.
And here, you have two specimens.
The upper one is cristobalite,
which is one of the several
crystalline forms of SiO2.
And here you see this is intensity
versus some function of angle.
And, as you expect, if something is
crystalline, you would get distinct
peaks. And those peaks come out of
the selection rules,
which you know on the basis of
constructive and destructive
interference. The lower trace is
that of amorphous silica.
Now, note carefully,
it's not a featureless spectrum.
It has one feature. It has one
feature. There's one broad peak.
And why is there one broad peak as
opposed to no peaks at all?
Because in silica, there is short
range order. I know what the local
environment is around every silicon.
It's four oxygens. We know the
silicon-oxygen bond distance,
and we know that each of these is at
109í from the central silicon.
And that gives rise to this one
broad peak.
After that, where the second nearest
neighbors lie depends on how those
backbones were twisted and turned at
the time that motion ceased.
So, the point here is that in the
glass, we have no long range order.
But we do have short range order
and the x-ray diffraction spectrum
gives us that quite vividly.
So, now, let's look at the
energetics of this.
Let's look at energetics of glass
formation.
First of all, which do we expect to
be lower energy,
the crystalline form or the glassy
form? Which one would be lower
energy? Well,
how do you attack a problem like
that? Well ask yourself,
what's the physical metric of energy
in this system?
It's bond formation.
We know that bond formation lowers
the energy of the system,
that is to say, makes it more
negative. So,
where do I form more bonds,
when things are tightly packed in a
crystalline array,
or when they're loosely packed in
this disordered glassy arrangement?
Well, clearly the crystalline array
gives us the most intimacy.
And so, therefore, we would argue
that the crystalline solid is at
lower energy. And,
it achieves lower energy by forming
more bonds via higher bond density.
Well, higher bond density would mean
that for a given mass of material,
if I have a higher bond density it
would be a more compact structure,
more bonds per unit volume. So,
this leads to volume as
a measure of disorder.
So, I want to show you a trace that
comes out of your reading.
This is from the lecture notes,
the archived lecture notes. And,
what we're looking at here is volume
on the ordinate as a function of
temperature. And,
we're going to look at this in some
detail. So, I'm going to spend a
little bit of time on this because
this teaches us what's going on in
these systems energetically using a
macroscopic measure,
the volume. It's trivial to measure
volume. You could use Archimedean
displacement. It's very
easy to measure volume.
All right, first of all,
there's a typo in the book,
excuse me, in the archive notes.
I think it's pretty clear that when
temperature falls,
it's cooling. So, just be mindful
of that. So, the first thing I want
to do is get you referenced against
the crystal. So,
I'm going to use T colors today,
all right? So, let's start, since
we're at MIT, we'll go on the red
line. OK, so here's the red line.
We start up here. We have a given
amount of silicate glass.
And we decrease the temperature.
That's what cooling means.
We decrease the temperature,
and if this is to form the crystal,
in other words, I cool slowly enough
that the atoms can rearrange,
as is typical of crystalline solids,
there is an abrupt change in volume
at the freezing point.
The liquid turns to solid and the
system contracts in a discontinuous
manner. The volume of the liquid is
substantially less than that of a
solid typically.
There's a few exceptions,
and we know what some of them are
such as ice, such as silicon,
and a few other important substances.
But, the vast majority of substances
pack more tightly in the solid state.
So, here we have the volume of
solidification,
and then as we continue to decrease
the temperature,
the volume decreases.
You know about thermal expansion,
right? What's happening in thermal
expansion? The atoms are moving
about their rest positions,
and so, here we finally get to a
temperature at which we have enough
energy to break the lattice energy.
And now, we does continuously jump
up to the liquid state,
and away we go. So, this is the
reference. And by the way,
notice one thing here, that the
change in volume per unit change in
temperature is much greater for a
liquid than it is for a solid.
And, you can continue that. The
unit change in volume per unit
change in temperature is greater for
a gas that it is for liquid.
I mean, this is the basis for
thermometry, right?
If you've got mercury in a glass
bulb, and temperature changes,
what you are betting is that the
unit change in liquid volume,
which is pretty much constrained in
one dimension because we have a very
tiny cross sectional area,
you are betting that the unit change
in liquid volume is substantially
higher than that of the unit change
in the solid volume,
in other words, if you will forgive
me the term, the glass thermometer
that contains the mercury.
It wouldn't do you any good if the
mercury were expanding and the glass
were expanding.
That would be useless as a metric,
wouldn't it? So, what we are
betting is that the unit change in
volume of the liquid is
substantially greater than that of
the solid. And,
you could see that that would be the
slope of this line.
This would be dV by dT.
And, I've indicated this.
This is the melting point.
Now, let's go down the green line.
Now we're going to go down the
green line. The Green line starts
up with the same liquid,
but we're cooling at a much more
rapid rate. We're cooling so
quickly that all of the atoms can't
twist and turn and find their
crystalline positions.
And so, we just go zooming right
through the melting point with no
substantial decrease in volume.
We continue to cool, cool, cool.
Down here, we're acting as a liquid
below the normal melting point.
We have supercooled liquid. And,
finally, we get to a temperature
below which the change in volume
levels out to that of what you would
expect down here in the crystal.
And, this knee in the curve is
called the glass transition
temperature. So,
above the glass transition
temperature, this material is
behaving as a liquid.
And, you know that viscosity is
strongly dependent upon temperature.
So, I'm not saying that this is
flowing like water.
It starts off flowing like honey,
and down here, it's flowing like
honey, the proverbial molasses in
January. It is viscous,
but very, very viscous. But finally,
down here, at this lower temperature
interval, it's immobile.
It's behaving as a solid.
But the interesting thing here is
that this knee in the curve is the
function of the cooling rate.
We have a rate dependent process.
As you'd expect, if I cool more
quickly, it's like musical chairs.
Instead of gradually decreasing the
volume, I just cut the volume.
So, let's do one more. So, by the
way, what's the point of all this?
I forgot. By the way, we said that
volume is a measure of disorder.
So, if we use, let's say, this down
here against the origin
is room temperature.
So, the projection of this lower
line would be the unit volume of the
crystal. And,
you could see the projection of the
upper line here is to a higher value.
And, that excess volume is some
measure of how much disorder has
been quenched in.
If the crystal had truly formed,
we would have the volume of the
crystal. So, let's do it again,
only this time we go much more
slowly when we cool.
If we go more slowly,
doesn't it stand to reason that the
system will have more
time to rearrange?
And so, therefore,
the amount of excess volume that
quenches in is not as great.
So, this excess volume is not
anywhere nearly as great.
So, what have we shown? We've
shown you a lot.
We've shown you the dynamics of
glass formation.
So, let's write this all down.
This is really good. What do we
see? We're looking at liquid to
solid transformation.
And, we have two possibilities.
We can either make a crystal or we
can make a glass.
That is to say, it can be
crystalline or amorphous.
And, how do we indicate? We
indicate solidification point.
The solidification, the metric that
we're using for solidification is
the knee in the curve of volume
versus temperature because we say,
we know we've achieved
solidification on the basis of
coefficient of thermal expansion.
Coefficient of thermal expansion of
the solid is substantially less than
the coefficient of thermal expansion
of the liquid.
So, if we're looking at V versus T,
we define the temperature at which
solidification has occurred when we
switch from the high value of the
liquid to the low value of the solid.
And the only difference between
solidification to form a crystal,
and solidification to form a glass
is that if we look at V versus T for
crystallization, I have
a steep slope up here.
I have a gentle slope down here,
and I have an abrupt change. I have
an abrupt change,
whereas in the case of glass
formation, V versus T,
this is glass formation.
In that case, again I have the
steep slope at high temperature.
I have the shallow slope at low
temperature.
But, there is no abrupt change.
So, this is called the melting
point, and this is called the glass
transition temperature.
In both cases, it is the
coefficient of thermal expansion
that clues you in,
because a glass formation,
there's no abrupt change in volume.
And, so this is going to be the
lowest volume.
And, this is the volume of the
crystal.
And, this is the volume of glass at
some particular cooling rate.
So, this is V1. And, just for
reference, V crystal is down here,
and this excess volume is the
measure of disorder.
Excess volume is the measure of
disorder. So,
we're in good shape.
Now, we can make the definitions.
Let's make the definitions, the one,
let's compare the two forms of
solidification.
So, the first one,
crystallization.
In both cases we are going from
liquid. In this case,
we go from liquid to crystalline
solid. And, this occurs at a
temperature called the melting point.
And, the melting point is not a
function of cooling rate.
As we are going to learn later,
it's a function of certain
environmental constraints: pressure,
composition, but it's not a function
of the cooling rate.
It doesn't matter if I cool water,
which does not form glass.
If I cool water slowly,
or if I cool it rapidly at one
atmosphere pressure,
100% water should change from liquid
to solid at zero degrees Celsius
always. OK, so,
the melting point independent of
cooling rate. Now,
contrast that with what we've
observed here for glass formation.
This is, again, a form of
solidification,
but it's a different end result,
same composition.
So in this case,
we have supercooled liquid.
It's liquid, but just to remind you,
it's liquid that's cooled below the
melting point,
T less than melting point.
And it transforms to glassy solid
or amorphous solid.
And, this occurs at a temperature
known as the glass transition
temperature T sub g.
And, unlike the melting point,
T sub g is a function of the cooling
rate. It's a function of the
cooling rate. So,
that's an engineering tool we can
use. If we want to quench in more
free volume, we cool at a higher
rate. If we want less free volume,
we cool at a lower rate. So, this
has to do with the intersection
between the theory, and the process.
So, that's what's going on in these
silicate glasses.
And, I don't want this to be so
narrowly focused as only on
silicates. There are other such
systems, in other words,
inorganic, covalent networks.
So, let's take a look at them,
other glass forming oxides. What
are we going to look for?
We're going to look for oxides that
have the capability of forming
covalent bonds.
Covalent bonding of the metal atoms,
of metal to metal, right, silicon is
more metallic than oxygen.
So, we have covalent bonding of
metal to metal via bridging oxygen.
Oxygen acts as the bridge between
the metal ions.
So, we never have two silicons
bonding to one another.
We always have a silicon to silicon
via the oxygen.
So, let's look at them.
Well, we've got silica. If we
believe Mendeleev,
then Germania should work.
GeO2 should work, so, germanate
glasses. We can also look at group
3, B2O3. Boric oxide can form
borate glasses.
And, I think I've got a slide of
that. Yeah, and on the left side,
we see boron as group three.
It forms sp2 hybrids.
So, sp2 hybrids will give you three
bonds, 120í in the plane.
So, this crystalline. This is
crystalline B2O3 on the left side,
whereas on the right side, you see
that sometimes there is the freedom
to twist. And,
as a result, this is not lying in
the plane. It's hard to see this,
but the right-hand image rises and
falls above and below the
plane of the projection.
And, the result is we have disorder.
And, you can see with the naked eye
here. Unit volume,
if we say in round numbers we have
the same number of atoms left and
right, you can see that the volume
of the glass is far in excess than
the volume of the crystal.
And, I could measure the change in
volume between that of the
disordered structure to that of the
ordered structure and say the
magnitude of that difference is a
magnitude of glassiness.
If this is only a small volume
larger, it's axiomatic.
Then it must mean it's darn close
to purely crystalline.
So, you can see very nicely.
So, this is borate glasses. And,
we'll say something about those
later. We can go to group five,
phosphate glasses, P2O5, vanadate
glasses, arsenate glasses,
and lastly, stibnate glasses.
So, these are all elements that can
form three-dimensional covalent
networks via bridging oxygens.
Now, let's look at the properties.
It's time to talk about properties.
We know enough. Let's go. They
are chemically inert.
How did we conclude this?
They are chemically inert.
I've got strong covalent bonds,
satisfied octet stability. These
things are not going to react with
other compounds because they are
stable the way they are,
electrically insulating.
How did I get that?
Same thing. When you have strong
bonds, whether it's strong ionic
bonds as in sodium chloride,
or strong covalent bonds as in SiO2
or diamond, strong bonds mean
tightly held electrons.
Now, remember, all that glitters is
not gold. But it must have free
electrons. So,
this will not be a good conductor of
electricity. In fact,
it is a good insulator.
If you go out on the street and you
see some of the old telephone poles,
you'll see some of these silicate,
they're typically brownish.
They are standoffs,
where the wires hang from cross
member to cross member.
They're all made out of these
materials. Mechanically brittle.
Strong bonds, we don't have the
shared smearing of orbitals as we do
in metallic bonds.
We don't have that.
We have things that are very strong,
very directional,
and so there's no possibility of
glide, optically transparent.
Yeah, I know because they are
glasses, right?
No, they are optically transparent.
Oxide glasses are optically
transparent. Metallic glasses,
not optically transparent. Why are
they optically transparent?
Strong covalent bonds. So
therefore, the energy levels are far
apart. And visible light,
with its puny two to three electron
volts per photon can't disturb the
inner workings of the glasses.
And, they are visually arresting
because they conform.
And, they don't have to form sharp
edges because they are amorphous.
So, I showed you last day, here's
some more of these Chihuly glasses.
How do you get the color? Where
does the color come from?
Where you get color? How do you
get the blue diamond?
Well, if the band gap is like this,
and photons of light are like this,
I need to park some dopant in the
band gap. This is band
gap engineering.
OK, so those are the properties of
the glasses. But,
there's one property I've neglected
to mention. With the strong bonds,
what do you think their melting
points are, high or low?
They're high, and that's a problem
because if I want to process these
glasses, I have to go to really high
temperatures. For example,
if you wanted to manufacture beer,
I mean, soda bottles, you don't want
to go up to 2,000íC
to melt the glass.
The energy costs are going to bury
you. So, what could we do?
If we were clever about the control
of composition,
maybe we could decrease the
processing temperature.
And, indeed, that is the case.
So, what I want to do is lower the
processing temperature by weakening
the bonds. Well,
what are the bonds?
They're strong covalent bonds.
So, I'm going to weaken them.
What I'm going to do is add an ionic
oxide. So, we want to lower
processing temperature by weakening
bonds. And, these are going to be
the bonds along the backbone,
silicon-oxygen bonds. So, the
gambit is to add ionic oxides.
So, let's look at one.
Here's a classic one: calcium oxide,
calcium two plus, oxide two minus,
good calciums from group two,
oxygen from group 16. We want an
oxide because we want something
that's soluble.
So, let's go. Let's dissolve
calcium oxide into silica.
So, we dissolve, and calcium oxide
is ionic. And it dissociates to
give calcium cations and oxide
anions. And then, the magic begins.
Here's oxygen in a bridging position
between two silicons.
And here's this free oxide ion.
So, this is the ion. This is a
bridging oxygen.
And what happens is this oxide ion
comes over here and says,
I can lower the energy of the system
by breaking this bond and turning
that structure into the following
one. Instead, oxygen
will insert itself.
And so, now the chain has been cut
here. The chain has been cut.
This was a free oxygen. And now,
the oxygen has attached itself to
one side of the broken piece of
chain, and the other oxygen remains
attached. And,
now I've got charge neutrality.
I've got a two minus here. So,
I'll put one minus here and one
minus here. So now,
the chain has been cut,
and just for grins and chuckles,
we'll bring over calcium as a
spectator to give us
charge neutrality.
So, what's the effect here?
The effect here is to shorten the
chain. And, what happens if you
shorten the chain?
Well, look at our factors that
promote glass formation: viscosity,
complexity, cooling rate. Which one
of those is affected by shortening
the chain? Viscosity.
If you've got long spaghetti
strands or short spaghetti strands,
OK, spaghetti, macaroni, which one
entangles? Which one's more
difficult to move around?
I know some of you haven't been in a
kitchen in a while,
but just imagine. Studying pasta
can teach you a lot about
macromolecular behavior.
All right, so clearly, these short
chains now have higher mobility,
lower viscosity. Well, if we have
lower viscosity then that's
equivalent to moving over to the
left here. That's going to decrease
our glass transition temperature.
So, this will help us process.
So, this act is called chain
scission. It gives us shorter
chains, and the result is higher
fluidity. And,
with higher fluidity,
we don't have the propensity to form
glass at the same temperature as we
otherwise would.
And so, this gives us the ability to
process at lower temperatures.
So, just to recap, the way to
represent that reaction is to show
this oxygen as a bridge.
This is bridging oxygen plus free
ion - ionic oxygen - gives us two
terminal oxygens,
terminal because each of these
oxygens ends the chain segment that
it's attached to.
And, it's got a little negative one
charge associated with it.
So, this is chain scission,
and this lowers Tg. So, that helps
us to process.
So, what is the menu of oxides that
we can use? I said we need
something that's ionic so it will
donate the O double minus.
If it doesn't donate O double minus,
it won't help us with this reaction.
So, there is a ton of oxides we can
use. Group one,
we can obviously use very metallic
oxides, lithium oxide,
sodium oxide, potassium oxide, etc.
We can pretty much use any group one
oxide. I've shown you calcium oxide.
If calcium oxide works,
what's an even more strongly ionic
oxide than calcium oxide out of
group two? Magnesium.
Of course, it's smaller,
got a higher charge density,
higher Madelung energy. Doesn't
that sound a little bit like quiz or
test number two? Yeah.
OK, so we could use any of the group
two oxides. They would work in
chain scission.
How about group three?
Any oxide donor, good oxide donor.
And, we use these. I'm going to
show you examples in commerce where
these are used,
not the first one.
Scandium oxide is not used.
It's so, so expensive. But
lanthanum oxide,
maybe, but in your catalytic
converter in the automobile,
you have yttria-stabilized zirconia
acting as the sensor.
And, we can use some group four.
Group four we could use lead oxide.
We'll see an example of that. Or,
you could use tin oxide.
This is the divalent oxide,
and this is the tetravalent oxide of
tin. So, these are all oxide donors,
and you will see various
combinations of these added to
glasses in order to achieve the kind
of chain scission that
we are looking for.
And here's some really interesting
data. This is XPS data.
This is XPS data. And, what we're
looking at is sodium oxide.
This is Na2O-SiO2. So, it's
slightly modified.
These materials, all of them,
I forgot, I meant to give the term
for all of these types of oxides,
the ionic oxides that engage in
chain scission,
the term used for all of these
oxides is network modifiers: to
modify the network by cutting
the chain length.
So these are called network
modifiers. So this is a slightly
modified network that these data
come from. And,
all of these are called network
formers. Let's get that up there.
These are all network formers.
Network formers,
we form the network,
we modify the network,
and tailor the properties.
So, this is a sodium oxide silica,
and overlooking at is XPS of two
different states.
We're looking at the oxygen 1s
electron in this particular system.
And the blue line is the raw data.
So if you had that blue line, you'd
say, gee, it doesn't have the shape
you'd expect. It lacks symmetry.
So, what you can do is imagine that
the blue curve is,
in fact, the sum of two separate
curves. And, there's a mathematical
technique called deconvolution that
says if the blue curve were the sum
of two properly configured curves,
what would they look like?
And so, what you do is you
deconvolve the blue curve into the
red and green curve.
So, if there were a red curve of
this magnitude,
and a green curve of this magnitude,
with the right symmetry, they would
sum to give us the blue curve.
And furthermore, we see that
there's two curves that have been
ascribed to bonding oxygen,
or what we call bridging oxygen,
and what I'm calling terminal oxygen
for the red, or they're calling
nonbridging oxygen.
So, you can actually tell the
difference in energy states of those
two oxygens because what you are
looking at is - this is the bridging
oxygen, and this is nonbridging
oxygen. And, we're looking at not
the valence electrons.
We're looking at the inner shell
electrons, the 1s.
And so, the presence of the silicon
on either side,
the presence on the silicon here on
either side as compared to the
presence of silicon only on one side
has an effect on what the 1s
electron in the two atoms senses in
terms of nuclear charge versus
screening of all the
electronic charge.
Clearly, in this case,
with the silicon, the silicon pulls
the electrons farther out than they
would be here because here you've
got nonbonding electrons not having
to go out. So,
in this XPS spectrum,
it's possible to see the subtle
difference in the energetics of the
two electronic states,
which I think is just so cool.
It's very elegant.
And so, let's keep going.
What's the worst we can do to
modify the network?
I said this is a long chain.
I keep cutting, and cutting, and
cutting, until in the extreme I'm
down to one unit.
I can't get any smaller than one
unit. So, what's one unit?
It's silicon with four oxygens: one,
two, three, four.
Silicons plus four: each of the
oxygens is minus two,
so this has a net charge of four
minus. So, it's just a single
complex anion,
right? It's just something with a
net charge of minus four.
And, this is called the
orthosilicate anion.
And, we could make a compound of
this stuff. We need to balance it
with some cation.
We can't just throw anions around.
So, if you had Ca,
calcium, you could take two times
calcium, one times orthosilicate,
this would be a salt. This would be
analogous to sodium chloride or
calcium fluoride,
only here you've got silicate as
your anion, and calcium,
this stuff here does not form glass.
This behaves as a molten salt. So,
it's very poor at glass forming,
and will crystallize on cooling.
Well, let's look at the compositions
of some of these glasses now that we
know we can engineer properties by
playing with a mix of former and
modifier. There's a few of them
worth looking at.
The first one is window glass,
soda lime. Well, it's soda lime
because it contains soda,
which is sodium oxide, and lime,
which is calcium oxide. What are
they doing? They are cutting the
chains, making the chains shorter so
that you don't have to heat window
glass to 2,000íC to process it.
You can process this stuff down
around 600-700íC.
Let's see, what else do we have
here? Borosilicate: this is the
workhorse for Pyrex.
You have two network formers.
You have silica and B2O3, with a
little bit of modifiers,
sodium oxide and alumina.
Alumina is added to give thermal
shock resistance.
And, thermal shock resistance comes
from a third category called
an intermediate.
And, an intermediate improves
thermal and mechanical behavior by
adding void space.
And it does this because of forms,
these are covalent. I'm going to
show you these are covalent.
They are covalent compounds but
with a different coordination
number.
In fact, their coordination number
is higher. Their coordination
number is greater than the
coordination number of the host
network. So, for example,
you see up here alumina, the typical
ones are alumina,
titania, or zirconia.
And these typically have
coordination numbers on the order of
six to eight, whereas silica has a
coordination number of four.
So, by having the higher
coordination number,
when you have rapid thermal change
the system doesn't shock and shatter.
Instead, there's room for flexure.
This allows for some flexure
because, remember,
plastic deformation is out of
consideration here.
There's no opportunity for such
things. So, you can see
evidence of that.
Here's some light flint optical
glass, 37% lead oxide.
So, what's the lead oxide doing?
Two things: first of all, lead
oxide up here is a modifier.
So, it's breaking the chains.
And secondly, lead is one of the
heaviest naturally occurring
elements. So,
it's got a lot of electrons.
So, lead oxide is going to have a
very, very high index of refraction.
And, in fact, if you put more than
24 weight percent lead oxide into
silica, you have enough chain
scission that when you cut that
glass, it will look as though it is
crystalline. And,
that's the basis for lead crystal.
It's lead oxide-modified silicate
glass. And, here,
they want to use it for high index
of refraction optics so that you
don't have to wear eyeglasses the
shape of Coke bottles.
You can now have something that's
very, very thin.
And now, they've been able to do
this and polymers to allow you to
get the performance that you need.
So now, here we look at,
this is the other curve from the
reading. It shows viscosity as a
function of temperature,
and as I mentioned earlier,
very strong temperature dependence.
But what you can see it is, here's
pure silica, SiO2.
And, if you're going to work with
the glass, you have to get the
viscosity down to about ten to the
fifth poise. Just for reference,
water is ten to the minus two poise.
It's one centipoise.
So, this stuff is very,
very viscous. And, it becomes more
and more viscous going through the
softening point and finally
annealing and strain.
And on the next slide are these
definitions. And they are posted at
the website. So,
you can go through.
They are also in the readings.
And all they're doing is defining
these different points in terms of
the change in viscosity.
In other words, it is a measure of
how quickly the atoms can rearrange
as a function of temperature that
defines these different breakpoints.
And these are not exact.
In other words, it's not as though
the working point is ten to the
fifth poise. If it's two times ten
to the fifth, you can't work with it.
It just becomes more and more
difficult to work with.
So, if you see people downstairs in
the basement of building four in the
glass shop, when they're taking
something out of the lair,
the furnace, when they take the
glass out and it's glowing red heat,
then it's up here in the regime of
working point.
And, as the glass radiates and the
temperature is falling,
they have a certain time window
during which they can form the glass.
And if the temperature gets below
the softening point,
at that point they are not going to
be able to shape the glass.
So, this is what you're seeing on
this slide. And,
you can see how the addition of
various elements,
if you take a constant value,
let's say, take the working
temperature, which is in round
numbers, ten to the fifth poise,
so for pure silica, we'd have to be
up here at around 2,000íC.
But if we add B2O3,
and some Na2O, now we are operating
at around 1,000 degrees.
And, if the ads of calcium oxide,
lime, now you're able to operate
down around 800í.
So, you can see how by changing
composition, through this mechanism
you can dramatically alter the
processing temperatures
of the various glasses.
And that's exactly what we're doing.
So, last thing to talk about is
strengthening of glass,
how to strengthen glass.
Glass is not too bad in compression,
but is very weak in tension.
So, two ways of doing it. First is
to thermally treat the glass.
We are going to exploit the fact
that glass has this dependence of
quenched in volume on temperature.
So, let's go back to this.
What we do is, in this case,
imagine we are going to treat the
windshield of an automobile.
So, we want to make it more
resistant to cracking if a stone
should hit it.
So, this is not to scale,
of course. This is glass that's
being processed.
It's in. It's above its softening
point. Rather than just let it cool,
and cool very slowly,
what we can do is send an air jet
along the surface.
And what that will do,
what the air jet will do is cause
the surface to cool more rapidly
than the center.
We know that glass is a poor
conductor of heat so we're not going
to expect to this going to be
isothermal. So,
I'm going to break this in half,
and then I'm going to take this part
and expand it,
OK? And, I'm going to divide the
top into two zones.
So, this is fast cooling.
And, the center is slow cooling.
And, likewise on the bottom side.
So, what happens? If you look on
this trace, it says fast cooling
gives me high excess volume.
So, I could say that when this is
finished, I could characterize it as
follows: that because the upper
portion cooled quickly,
it should occupy a large volume.
And, the lower portion cooled
slowly. It wants to occupy
a smaller volume.
But, they are joined.
So, what does that require?
It requires it all be one volume.
So, that means the lower part is
going to force the upper part in.
So, when the thing, in fact, looks
like this, we know that the upper
part is on the influence of strong
compressive stresses.
And as a result, if a stone hits
this, instead of simply having to
break the bonds,
it has to overcome all of the bonds
plus the added stress that has been,
the material is pre-stressed.
So, now, in order to break this,
I have to break both the bonds plus
pre-stress. And,
again, if you study this V versus T
curve, you can convince yourself
that high cooling on the outer edge
will give you a higher volume.
But, the material is not allowed to
delaminate. So,
in fact, the surface has a
compressive stress that is built-in.
OK, well, there are other ways to
strengthen it.
Let's see, here's one.
There's the ability to
recrystallize glasses.
In this case, what is done is to
introduce crystalline material into
the glass during the cooling process.
So, now we're going to combine the
properties of crystals with glasses.
And, this is work that began back
in the 50s at Corning under Stookey.
And, what they did was they added
nucleating agents to the glass melt.
And, these nucleating agents do not
dissolve. They are floating around
like grains of sand in honey.
And, they cause the honey to
crystallize out.
And the result is that when this
thing grows to completion,
what we have is a material that is,
these are the various grains.
During solidification,
these start to solidify,
nucleate crystalline glass.
When these grow to impingement,
we have something that is in many
instances 95% crystalline.
And the only glass is this mortar in
between, 5% glassy.
And, these are the glass ceramics
which if you go to grandma's house,
you'll see this stuff here.
Remember these?
This is Pyroceram glass.
It's 95% crystalline, the grain
size of about 1 micron,
which is large enough to scatter
light. And that's why it's white
because this is a high
band gap material.
It should all be transparent to
visible light.
But this is white for the same
reason that table salt is white.
A large single crystal of sodium
chloride is transparent.
But if you crush it up in a fine
powder it appears white because of
the scattering.
That's what you see here.
And this was designed by Corning,
which by the way doesn't make
Corning Ware anymore.
They moved into optoelectronics and
so on, fiber optics.
So anyways, if you see this on eBay,
you know that this is Pyroceram.
It has amazing toughness.
I used to have a demonstration.
I had one of these, a sauce pan,
and I hold up a 2 x 4 and drive a
roofing nail into the 2 x 4 using
the PyroCeram saucepan as the hammer.
These things have enormous strength,
and they are also transparent in the
microwave region.
They are great in the thing,
and I'm not trying to do a cooking
show here. I'm just telling you
that these are engineered materials.
All right, now, next one is visions.
This is visions.
Maybe you've seen some of that
around. The only difference between
visions is that the crystallites are
submicron size.
And so, now, they remain transparent
to visible light,
and they index match them so that
the index of refraction of the
glassy mortar is the same as the
index of refraction of the
crystalline material.
And then, they dope with transition
metal so that it looks sort of like
the old copper,
elegant, chi-chi upscale cookware.
And, also you can charge a premium
over plain, clear,
colorless Pyrex. And so,
all of this is done by engineering
of the molecular architecture.
I'll see you on Wednesday.